President Trump had a physical today did
you know that he had his physical what
the hell is that
it's fine what I'm looking for was sort
of a oh yeah he had a he had his
physical everyone's talking about his
health yes
president this is the latest president
Trump's this is true president Trump's
doctor predicted that the president will
have and live a long life as a result as
a result the doctors now treating
Melania Trump for depression
I like these thank you sir I'm getting
you're the worst David Caruso in person
I know it was murder after Trump's exam
true story his doctor said he found
quote no cognitive or mental issues
whatsoever with the president yeah ah
but the doctor did say keep in mind I am
a proctologist okay I know
yesterday President Trump broke with
tradition and he spent Martin Luther
King Day playing golf instead of
performing a community service yeah
however many people say that any time
Donald Trump's not in the White House
he's performing a community service
I should have these every night sure
yeah how to get a pair of these on my
own I just don't know Mormon Church is
in the news the Mormon Church has picked
a new leader and he's 93 years old yeah
which is why they're getting together on
Friday to pick another you just
applauded a man passing away
and that's that's on all of you that's
on you that's on you get this miners in
Africa have found a massive 910 carat
diamond worth tens of millions of
dollars massive yeah the diamond will go
to either a museum or do you Beyonce the
next time jay-z cheats on her they don't
[Applause]
you